the immune system basically protects us
from pathogens so a pathogen is a virus
like at the common cold or it's a
bacterial infection or it's a parasite
and these pathogens can make us
realistic and our immune system protects
us from these the way that the immune
system does this is that it's very good
at telling the difference between what
self and what's non-self and and so
non-self obviously is anything like a
virus or bacteria so our immune system
is very good at picking up anything that
doesn't belong to our bodies and
rejecting it
all cells in our body have a very
distinct set of markers or proteins on
their cell surface and these act as a
barcode and the immune system can read
these cells this barcode and it
immediately sends a signal that that
cell is foreign and not part of the body
and needs to be destroyed immediately or
that it's a self cell and it's fine
harmless leave it alone so these devil
facial tumour disease cells should
automatically be recognized by the devil
immune system as something that's
foreign that's come from another animal
but for some reason that doesn't happen
the way that this cancer in the
Tasmanian Devil does this is that it
changes what it looks like it it puts on
a disguise
they're changing the proteins and
markers they have on their cell surface
which means that the devil immune system
can't see them